Sky News understands the Prime Minister
Boris Johnson will not face a police
investigation into allegations over his
links while Mayor of London with the
American tech entrepreneur Jennifer our
curry and John is now is our political
correspondent tomorrow Cohen who has the
details tomorrow Adam that report will
be coming out shortly but I understand
it will find that the prime minister did
not commit any wrongdoing according to
this report by the independent office of
police conduct there is no criminal case
for the prime minister to answer over
his relationship with the American
entrepreneur Jennifer R Curie you
remember he was referred last year after
it was revealed that when he was mayor
of London and of course responsible for
police saying that's why the police
watchdog has looked into this it was
revealed that he had taken her on a
number of official trade trips and her
company had secured funding from the
mayor's promotional agency London and
partners to the tune of over ten
thousand pounds so he was referred with
a view to possible charges of misconduct
in a public office but I understand the
independent office of police conduct
have found that he there is no case to
answer for the prime minister so I think
there'll be sighs of relief in Downing
Street that they hope that this chapter
will come to an end I've seen a
reference from other news sources that
the investigation does refer to a
possible intimate relationship between
the two is that what you understand I
haven't heard that Adam certainly and
they were described as having a close
friendship this Sunday times he break
the story and cited sources saying that
sheets she said it was one of her best
friends
Jennifer are Kerry herself is given TV
interviews talking about their close
friendship and other people have alleged
that the two of them were having an
affair but I'm not sure whether the IO
PC report actually goes into the nature
of their relationship that certainly
it's been widely reported to have been a
very close friendship and this I'll
carry herself said
television in the last few months that
she thought mr. Johnson should have
declared their friendship officially
when he was married London and she
claimed that he was concerned that
people might wonder if there was a
conflict of interest